t 種
t you do
きっとマリアカラスこんにちは
私はですね最近がドラゴンだとか
はじめて聞きましたすいません笑は誘えないと思います
a でも共通しているかはみんな関東ですよ
会は勉強というのも勉強キライなんですけど
感動するのは対しですね
で今までもどんなコン行ってきましたけど
年次数回体が
はな場だそういう環境委員であると思います
それは研究です
ブーバーしちょちゃっますよ
どうもみなさんと一緒にちょっと考えてみたいと思います
a アンチっあるいは春
なさったことがあると思います渡りが飛んでいいですか
非常にきれい直成長にならん
あるいはピノ人があったとっていく
やれ
編隊飛行ですね
エイムではフォーメーション夫妻という
でこのトリガーたんで直線になって道路下の子なんだったものかというのは最近分かっ
てきました
それはとり楽部とポリの羽の先端に桐生
両辺鑑賞してそれをうまく利用して後ろの鳥がエネルギーを少なくして飛んで行くと
言うんです
そうすると植生やっていきますね
hey ちょうど私のアイディアはこれを宇宙でできないかというです
フォーメーション fan space
by ぱ15衛生平成は鳥のように飛ぶことができるかということです
hey 仮にこれが飛んだとしてちょっと兄が嬉しい
鳥のように富んだかけたん面白い曲じゃないがアップし部下
ロスあっ私が思いついたのはあっっ
パティとつづったくさんあっうんちっませんっ
この日あるしカメラをセター
複数のカメラで地面をとらえることができますそうするとどんな
あそぼトレイ
yeah yeah
よくある三角側近と同じようので
一体的な画像が問われるはずです
普通皆さんよく見ている人工衛星から写真という
は
4件きらっちが仏陀の批判だろたいかそうだと思いますけどこれが実態的になっ
あるいはこれが複数の平成で飛んで行くとあるの同じましょう
まあさっ今回のは御嶽山の[ __ ]なカーサですねそういったものが痴漢て均等変わって
いくかっていうのがパーンパーン分かるはずまり以下までも a
ぶっぶーぶーっ kyoraku しかーし
a これは一つの手ですね age 枚あそぼ台風を捉えたりしています
でもなんかちょっと優れた感じに見えます
あるいはこの下にあるのはフランスの遅れし
1件そっから奪ったどんだけさんお写真です
上から見ると確かに火山が参加して運営が出てますけど何かあっ日あっていますこれを
を知ったいっにした
火山噴火がどれぐらいまで当たっていうか
それがどういうにとってどれくらい広がっていく感じなんです
将来予測できますですねあるいはか3倍がどの場所
どれぐらい積もってい
それを複数の衛星に行くと仕事にどう変化していくかっていうのが行われます
これは非常に a 環境を調べる
もの方法だと
実はフォーメーションフラインっていうのは私は今実はちょっと簡単ではありません
契約しています
ハーレパーツ小さくなりますわーヨーロッパだあれパーカアーレ image here
till しています
ブーブー小さくかあの一度1台は私が担当していかあこれはちょうど地域沿線へ
here へいほうめー
一生使い残念だからこれ h つってません
えっ
花敷町に設置して飛んでいて
可能秘書系
どう残念なレンズっていないその後までを離れていますけれども私を近づけ
これがに3週間に1回そういうチャンスを
じゃあその同時に撮った画像から
ジャックもん一帯が前とれるかっていうと残念ながらその手法はは確立されていません
私もちょっとこれくらい考えてるんですが im 川でぜひここに皆さんこうやったら
できゅんベルトを教えてください
あのそしたら早速あれ採用したいと思います
ちょっと地球に戻ります
さっきの変態でもじゃあこのへんな日をできるのかというとこれは一つのファイルです
a 地中の空気
皆さん9チームは
ブーブーいっきまーし
デジ os や宇宙ステーションという風コーデ100キロから100人もありません
そこ
全く親父じゃありません地球の空気パドゥリオン
羽が使えるかもしれん
シャー言っますかあ2
地球のブーイングに近し
いうと空地も濃くなっていくね
そこであっ男やると
gose 速度を変えたり遅くしたり
あり版着艦方
まあこれ残党を計算しているとまあ使うのではないんだと言うんです
でこれができると
将来紅
ターンこういうものが実現するだと思います地球の周りにたくさんもせる
たくさんの人口平成を飛ばしてやってみんなで仲良く
観察したべ
でそれをいろんな首相だとか最大
逆に立てるそういう発想ですん
で皆さんを知っていると思いますけれども人工衛星は必ずコンピュータ包まれています
で沈降性は非常によくできた顔音です
威厳がいちいちこんな即時はしていません私立して覚えています
これにネットワーク機能を載せます
by ちんこーえーせプッチン os お互いに
犬落車ところ衛生貫通しています
をそれをすることによって複数の usb がお互いに全額を取りながらきちんととっ
てるから
押しこれが完成すれば
ある場所
h 11以下ああっちゃー犬2位
人一人ぐらい私はちょっと重いかもしれませんが
女の人一人分くらいの人工衛星を100機作るとだいたい日本の気象偽
一国のであるでありますですから全く使うことはない
でこれはもう技術的にできてしまう
私は興味はもうちょっと頭部に入っちゃいましたね
a それは私たち対応型
地球も含めで月あるいはか声優人生
そんな木製正体を音がありますそういうところ
探査機1まっ炭酸あるいは10号 s 本1本
て体温 a 全体お弁当はお菓子
ええっとワークというと
たスマホ色々使っていると思いますが地球のれる
パックを絡んだ地球の上の表明
やるシゲティラーメンです
ところがこれを三次元的置換
惑星あるいは月と潰し必要ですそこには同市と時間差が生じます
どうしてもこれは虚資源的なネットワーク型てあると言う
じゃあ将来こんなことができるとうれしいんだと気がします
例えばへ
か整理パスとストーカーしたそれ用の投稿にいて
5パパッと a computer も知れたに仕事ができる
あるいは北西に粉が無限したらしちょっと秒
あるいは木星の衛星表には火山が鳴ります
ですからこのかあさん今すごい顔勝永チョコ差負けしたろー
あるいは行き下にあるような都政の衛星タイタン
これには彼は彼は得意があります
残念ながら留守けどなくてメタンできていますけれどもそれが
長はお話はなくちゃ流れている感じですね
あるいは7000万年ぐらい
者が小惑星が地球に衝突して共有がを込めてしまいました
そういう小学生が今んとこ撮った地球に向かっている
そういうのはたぶん将来わかるんでしょってその日立館であるんさつ
第二集どこに行こうかな大衆どうか製のダストが
下がりそうなちょっと稼い入ってくる
そういう将来がタウン近いうちになってるでしょ
ここにいる若い人たちが生きて生まれたリターンを達成できたことはない
私はたぶんこのようなにはないと思いますけれど
え財布
たぶんこういう会話が普通に行われるようになるんじゃないかと思います
おちりさんおばあさん訴え特化したの彼方
どうありがとうございました